it appears kim kardashian and kanye west
are no longer
on speaking terms it's been a journey
back in february kim
officially filed for divorce citing
irreconcilable differences with the
rapper
and now a source tells e.t that kanye
hasn't been speaking to kim directly
recently
it's so hard the source goes on to say
that kim sees this as kanye having
another episode
and it is definitely concerning to her
especially in regard to their kids
in 2016 it was revealed that kanye
suffers from bipolar disorder
you know i've seen him go through a lot
kim and kanye also share four children
seven-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago
and one-year-old psalm the two are
currently seeking joint
and legal custody which another source
tells et is making the transition easier
for kanye amid their divorce
what does it mean to you to have this
family now kanye and you
it's given me a whole perspective an
understanding of what to work for
what to live for and an understanding of
how other families
you know operate put things in
perspective and it does make you
just you know like everyone goes through
this
and you have no idea what it really is
like until you go through it yourself
but it's the best feeling to have your
own family and kids and
it's the best other than focusing on
their children kim and kanye seem to be
heading in different directions
on sunday it was announced kanye won a
grammy award for the best contemporary
christian album for his latest project
jesus king
i'm just extremely happy meanwhile kim
made a virtual appearance at the kids
choice awards on saturday
my kids can barely believe it when i
said i was going to be in it
a source tells e.t kim is just taking
the time to focus on herself and her
family
and continuing to work and grow her
business a similar sentiment she shared
this week in a new interview with vogue
i think that this year has been
so challenging for so many people but i
also think that this year
was a huge cleanse i always try to look
at things for
in the positive way so you know even
though it's been such a challenging year
i think it's been a time to regenerate
get creative
spend so much time with family
and just this time that i've been able
to spend with my children has been on
you know
[Music]
priceless